welcome back to new rockstars the latest
episode of moon knight had us getting
our lara croft on and riding some tombs
only to find ourselves waking up to one
flew over the consciousness with a hippo
version of nerds ratched what is going
on this is rogue theory the show where
we pitch the wildest theories for the
nerdy titles that we love my name is mt
and going rogue with me today is my
personal psychiatrist it's jessica
clemens hello jessica thank you for
watching taking the time no i know we
just
i don't hold anything in confidentiality
if anybody wants mt's phone number i'm
going to yell it out right now it is
i didn't know that we were allowed to
bring our therapists as guests on rogue
theory now that i know this
that would be amazing you guys get ready
to hear dr burris takes on the mcu i'm
gonna call her right now ken my
therapist is too hot and i don't want
anyone commenting on it
he's perfect if you guys are looking for
a single man he's 33 is that the age for
hotness yes 33 yes i think man i'm about
to be 30 next month so i'm almost there
three years i'm at 31. i have two more
years until i'm hot you guys two more
years i can i can do this i was hot it's
come and gone
the sexy 33s i love it
and obviously someone who's always
stealing my winning bingo card it's
whitney van landingham what's going on
oh man just stealing some bingo cards
you know you know how you almost have
been going up to a bingo hall and just
being like you old people i'm here to
steal your winning cards i have a feud
with a woman named edna she's always
winning me winning at bingo i think
there's a conspiracy i'm coming for you
edna dude opal and mod
they
that'd be an amazing sitcom edmond mod
to go to bingo
um anyway um and finally the man i keep
locked away in a sarcophagus until it's
time for the next rogue theory it's tom
michaelson what's going on what's up
still a little bit bright in here but
i'll try to acclimate i usually come out
only at night
but uh you know for mt and for the game
you know theory in like two weeks
yeah yeah
yeah esophagus oh my god he was shaking
himself out of the sarcophagus
thousands of years ago so that's what i
was talking about i actually was 33 a
millennia ago me and ensa manure were
youngins running around
right now to rise and do some rogue
theory
all right
well the ending of moon night episode 4
was certainly the most bizarre thing
we've seen happen in a series that has
already has some pretty crazy moments
and we've all been sharing our thoughts
around the office about this episode so
we've got to start there for our
discussion today so
our first topic of today is how will
steven and mark escape the psychiatric
ward and if they do escape what reality
will they face on the other side because
the corporeal body they share was shot
by arthur harrow very rudely i might say
he was
not a very nice thing to do to um
someone that you had lentil soup with
yeah what a dick they shared soup and
now he's acting like this that's your
soup bro man soup bro you can't do this
to your soup bro rude
the bond the two men form as they share
a bowl of lentil soup is is unbreakable
you can't just exert that
jesus christ no no honor hero no honor
there's no honor that's what knuckle
would say
dishonor no
but anyway um so
how will they be able to return to the
real world and if it is the world we've
been shown in the first four episodes
reality or is the real world something
that we haven't seen yet on the show
what do you guys think i don't know man
that was a
do you guys think that this reality
could be all in mark and steve's heads
i'm wondering if it's like some sort of
thing where
like arthur harrow
is like has the power to alter reality
kind of like you know obviously the
reality stone like i was thinking about
like you know that scene in it um in
infinity war when gamora shows up to
kick thanos ass at the uh collector's
museum on nowhere and he's like created
this whole illusion that like
like he kicked the collector's ass but
there's still some time to save him and
then he like reveals like nope i already
burned this place to the ground and you
can't do anything about it and so i'm
wondering if like maybe amit is able to
give him the power to create
that same sort of like reality illusion
and so now that's why mark is like stuck
in this weird psychiatric facility
because he
i think it could just be like a
you know like a reality twisted mind
situation does this make sense because
maybe i'm crazy
no no no i'm following with you 100
because like is are you like sort of
like like sort of like a hero vision
yeah scenario it's like all right
but have hair revision
or image vision i don't know
like for last halloween so now what if i
do hero vision for this halloween you
got it that's my costume it's put glass
in your shoes
now it's the new season of wild
divisions
but no i really like that idea because
like me personally i feel like chaos
magic is very much a factor in this show
between both archer hero and uh moon
knight so you know it'd be really cool
if we had that chaos magic manifest in
this way where like we are in a like in
the physical real world but now arthur
harrow has just physically changed
everything to mess with mark and to sort
of you know toy with him a little bit
even though he shot him with a gun
let's be really messed up i shot you
healed you and now i'm gonna mess with
you in hero vision it's terrible it's
like dude just let him let him go to bed
let stephen have to let me go to bed for
once
please just let him out let me go to bed
unchained for once in my life just one
nap i swear to god just one little nap
like just let him have it
poor baby i love steven so much i just
don't want him he's such a sweet bee and
i love him so much sweet little bean
sing one of these days i'm going to be
able to kiss him on the forehead
sweet boy
just kidding but what do you guys think
yeah i think that you know in a weird
way i think that what might happen is
probably the most magical unrealistic
thing like maybe tarot the hippo goddess
you know she she's a goddess of birth
and fertility so maybe she's gonna help
him be reborn back into the world that
but even though that's like so magical
and crazy but
how nuts would it be though if the if
the most grounded realistic version was
what happened where he you know he
walked out the door and nothing that
we've seen is real everything has been
in his mind made up and now there's a
different kind of show for the last few
apps it'd be really tough to pull off
but how badass would it be like a you
know 12 monkey situation right with like
bruce willis when he was like wait was
am i am i imagining what happened in
that future am i crazy and then the
whole show ends up being even more
you know of them delving deep into that
about what's real and what's not i don't
think they could do it because it'd be
really tough to pull it off in the sixth
sense
yes any bruce willis really yeah no no
what if he's just like at the end he's
like a six-year-old haley joel osment
tells moon knight that he's been dead
the whole time
that would be bananas you've been dead
for 45 years every character on the show
is actually dead
what if it's lost what if it's just lost
to the show what if it's just the one
yeah i don't think they could
lost that starts or ends
but i believe you
i've never seen it's a confusing romp
it's a fun but a confusing romp yeah
see i i didn't start lost because i know
that it ends in a weird way so i'm just
like why am i going to do that yeah i'm
like that's just setting myself up for
disappointment but it's not how you get
there
the journey
i believe it i believe that the
journey's gone all right yeah yeah but
what you got for us jess but i do like
that top i do but uh what you got for us
jess um
trying to think of a rogue answer
[Music]
brandon had was specifically with me
um
for those listening i was told to go
roger instead of writer so
what
what if um how will stephen and mark
escape the psychiatric ward
what if give me a second it's gonna come
to me it's it's gonna be so crazy
it's gonna be so nuts
because what happens if
layla
we're actually in layla's freaking mind
right what if we're actually in layla's
mind because layla's actually ahmed so
this is what we're seeing through
ahmed's eyes they're actually an ahmed
like ball field they're in her turf so i
think they're all just unconscious what
have you and i think the dead version of
mark in them are supposed to be going to
somewhere else but instead they got
intercepted on the way because emmett's
little
statue came out of the mouth of
alexander the great so they're on now
where ahmed is actually staying and
ahmed is somewhere hiding in this
building that they're trying to escape
from
but ahmed is actually layla and laila's
just not gonna let them go she's trying
to play it like she's wild right now
with the scarab band-aid but it's like
yeah you're the scarab because you're
actually ahmed yo
goof
yeah damn that would be again
we know it's you
damn you're actually i'm
i love that a lot because like we i
there's something about layla that we
haven't seen yet in this show like
there's some secret this big i don't
know whether she's the the scarlet
scarab or or something um if she is a
scarlet scarab the scarlet scare of the
scarlet witch really just link up and
have a little scholarship
too many scarlets just one please
and johansen comes along they all sell
all the scars
but we also don't know what happened to
layla after mark got shot because she
was just chilling in the room with all
these bad guys so um and it just it
would be really interesting to if like
caro ended up taking her and like doing
some weird ritual and like she ended up
messing things up and like messing up
reality like you're in my world now
country was able to overpower and
colonize uh steven's mind because it was
weak or broken what have you what if
layla's is also kind of easy to break
into and as soon as they pulled out that
statue ahmet was looking for an avatar
and controlled layla
that's rogue you see i like that a lot
you said you didn't have it yeah
that is the most broke because i i
really like that because i think that
ahmet or whoever's playing games with
harrow would totally take layla as a
host because we saw what she did with
her necklace she was really resourceful
she stabbed that dude right in the
shoulder this area i would not i
wouldn't want to be stabbed
i've been rubbing this area too long
[Laughter]
but
yeah it's um it's yeah she's like she's
a really she's a badass chick we saw at
the beginning of the last episode she
took out that entire those machine gun
people pretty
like easily with a flare i couldn't
do that at all like what like i would
never if there was just like a bunch of
dudes with guns i would not be like let
me set off a little baby mini firework
like that would never cross my mind i
thought you're gonna do a jurassic park
situation died so hard
like i thought she had like a stick of
dynamite
i thought no i seriously thought we were
about to see like some wily coyote [ __ ]
[Laughter]
she pulls out her acme box
take this
there's a hole in the side of the dude
on the side of the cave
she throws up like a big black dot so
that they think it's a tunnel and all of
them just snack into it
we honestly need a superhero like that
in the
let's get to writing this script as soon
as we're done with rogue's theory we're
right we're writing a looney tunes
superhero movie i think jess is uh just
his theory on this i never thought of
that but what if yeah what if like we're
in layla's mind and or or this is like
almost like the conscious holding zone
right like everybody in there either
avatar's country wants or avatars that
he had right like heroes in there um and
then we have stephen mark and then layla
who he really wants what if this is some
yeah what if this isn't in one of their
minds or this is in conscious kind of
because since now that he's a statue
maybe he's been semi not destroyed but
you know what i mean he maybe he's not
even aware of what's happening this is
where all the avatars go or something
like that when she said that i was like
oh [ __ ] that's really cool i hadn't
thought about that and now what you're
saying is making me think about
um you know the scene in harry potter
seven
rowling but uh you know the scene in the
movie where like
uh harry like dies and he goes to king's
cross station and it's like it's all
white just like this was and he like
talks to dumbledore and it turns out
that it's like a kind of purgatory where
your soul is waiting to see if you're
gonna die or go back so i wonder if
that's like what this place is because
mark is currently
straddling the line between life and
death because he just got shot now his
two personas are separated and
apparently outside of the body like and
i bet this is one of those things where
time acts different too where you know
we're going to watch a whole episode
here yeah and yet it happens in a
fraction of a second like in yeah just
like in harry potter i honestly think
that that could actually be the case
because like for in my opinion i think
that this is all cerebral i think this
is all happening within mark's head
because like there i think that that's
the only reason why we could be seeing
him and steve hug hug it out because
like it's like it's a very cerebral
thing and i i really love that moment a
lot a lot it was very awesome and uh at
first i was like how did they make that
happen that's impossible but then i was
like oh wait this is not real um
i got sad when i realized it wasn't real
though because like obviously like when
you're watching a show and you're in the
moment you're like oh everything is
actually happening like this and i
literally thought the thoughts oh thank
god that there's just two oscar isaacs
now because then that means i can
definitely take at least one of them
and then i had to remember that he's not
real that's called cinematography
damn new cinematography lies only lies
but no i think that this is all cerebral
so i think that this could actually take
place within
like fractions of a second because your
brain electricity is really fast um but
no these were all really fantastic
theories i know i always say that but
like i always mean it because you guys
are so great but i'm going to give jess
20 000 rogue points because her theory
was super rogue and it was actually very
like kind of impossible like i think
it's rogue and plausible and those are
the best kinds of rogues theories but
your theories were also great so 15 000
rogue points to each of you because
those are some pretty dang good theories
i really liked hero vision a lot because
i feel like that
happens
everyone has a cane
yes and they're doing you know like one
of those little like like yeah like that
yes yes oh
all right but
but up next we are going to talk about
the baddie who killed leyla's daddy but
first if you want to talk about moon
knight with us in a completely new way
new rockstars is now on tumblr that's
right if you're a tumblr regular a
lapsed user or even completely new to
the platform come check out the fun
stuff we're doing on the tumblr machine
right now our own jessica clemons who's
right here listening to me speak about
her and social media master tyler are
hanging out on our tumblr account and
having way too much fun doing it so
check us out at the new rockstars
official tumblr but also if you like
star wars and you also enjoy wearing
insanely comfortable and stylish
underwear i know i do me undies has a
new star wars collaboration that you're
going to want to see immediately me
undies is back with more prints
featuring your favorite characters get
ready for your next movie marathon with
the softest and comfiest star wars
collection we love me undies here at new
rockstars they're a delight to get in
the mail and producer zack has been
rocking one of the star wars prince and
they've become one of his favorites he
won't stop texting me about it it's kind
of strange meundies loves partnering
with your favorite shows and movies and
this isn't the first time they've
created a collection with star wars the
force is strong with this one which is
why they're back with two limited
edition prints light speed and rebel
squadron so match your favorite person
in the galaxy in sustainably soft undies
socks loungewear dog hoodies and more
with in sizes extra small up to four x
nb undies has a great offer for my
listeners for any first time purchasers
you get 15 off and me undies shipped
right to your door to get 15 off your
first order and 100 satisfaction
guaranteed go to meundies.com
rockstars that's meundies.com
rockstars and hey our researcher anna
recently heard a great story from her
mom that inspired her to get her mom's
story worth as a gift and she wondered
how many great stories don't i know
sorry worth is an online service that
helps you and your loved ones connect
through sharing stories and memories and
preserves them for years to come every
week story worth emails your mom a
thought-provoking question of your
choice from a vast pool of possible
options each unique prompt asks
questions you never thought of like
what's some of the best advice your
mother gave you or if you were to do it
all over what would you do differently
and you'll really enjoy reading your
mom's answers to those questions and
your mom will have a blast sharing those
stories and who knows maybe your mom
dated the inventor of the swizzle straw
or she beat your aunt in a pie eating
contest that turned hilariously violent
after one year story worth compiles all
those questions and stories including
photos into a beautiful keepsake book
the whole family can share for
generations so give all the moms in your
life a meaningful gift that you'll both
cherish for years story worth right now
for a limited time you'll save ten
dollars on your first purchase when you
go to storyworth.com rogue that's s t o
r y
w o r t h dot com slash rogue to save
ten dollars on your first purchase
storyworth.com
rogue all right guys
you guys ready for another topic for
rogue theory because i've got another
one for you let's do it do you
because one of the revelations that was
made clear to layla in this episode was
the involvement of mark spector in her
father's death kind of awkward should
have brought that up at least before the
wedding um maybe the the night before
the wedding be like oh yeah i was there
when your dad died all right let's get
married tomorrow
um but only he claims it wasn't him so
that leads us to our second topic of
today
who was mark's partner because mark
mentioned that he was working with
someone during the job that wound up
when the death of laila's father so yeah
is this the dude champ we saw in mark's
phone or is this another persona or is
this straight up a lie what do you guys
think i'm really sorry guys it was me
i was well i knew it i knew it i was
gonna tell kevin how i had my suspicions
and i was jealous because my dad never
loved me so i was like i'm taking
layla's what if it was hey
understandable it's an understandable
reaction and now i have to go to therapy
because i'm a scary murderer she did it
on father's day i did it on father's day
and also my favorite memory is gonna put
out an episode about me asap it's gonna
be like the egyptian deity killer
whitney van lang
in her private military contractor days
yeah
can you even see me being in the
military like jesus christ i would get
thrown out i would love to see you in
like decked out and cannibal with your
like beautiful purple hair yeah
i would not survive the portion of the
military where they make you do pull-ups
i have no upgraded strength
oh this is the private the png's where
you get hired you're not a real army so
it's good they'll just take you how you
are it doesn't matter
as long as you want to pull the trigger
for them
um actually you guys i was lying i
didn't kill leila's dad and i don't know
who did
i don't know
well we don't know this whole episode is
just weird well one of you three knows
who did all right i heard he knows who
did it and we're not kidding that's why
i've gathered you here today this is
actually interrogation it was mr green
in the billiards room with a rope does
that count is that rogue enough for you
brandon
yeah like do you guys have any idea like
we're like um do you think that it could
be this duchamp guy yeah i think well i
think yeah that they're probably going
to do something one thing cool about
these marvel shows is that
it seems like there's a trend down the
last one or two apps they introduce this
new character that's gonna or or they
introduce somebody that's gonna have a
future in the mcu like whether it's
white vision
or um you know kang the conqueror is now
coming through
um or in hawkeye they introduced kingpin
so there's i think there's gotta be
somebody that's coming that you know
it'd be cool if it was someone like
killmonger like in a flashback or some
bad truck it'd be cool if it was someone
we already knew
um but i'm wondering we'd love to see if
mark and killmonger had a pass together
he's one of the yeah he's one of the
dopest uh you know mercenaries we've
seen yeah i hope it's kilimanjaro too
but i'm wondering if they're gonna
introduce somebody new so if we're gonna
go rogue if brandon said that we gotta
go rogue then i i'm i hope it's
i hope it's uh billy russo who if you
remember is frank castle's best friend
the private military contractor from
punisher and i hope that this is the way
to get punisher in the mcu we've already
got charlie cox we've already got
kingpin bring john bernthal because he
is the punisher i want to see i want to
see them open up that door because i
need a yeah i need to get some mcu
punisher stat that would be bad
yo ben barnes is a handsome dude that is
mary has a man and a handsome man i
would love to see him in the mcu and
like i i i need to see more of that
netflix marvel tie-ins to them yes
because like
in no way
in hawkeye but like we it'd be joke yes
what if danny rand
killed playlist
that's why i said the best parts because
not everything from the netflix shows
needs to come over oh my
god you know we don't need
everything um yeah i think that um
layla's dad didn't believe that he was
from kunlun until he had to take him out
because he says it only every other
sentence he starts like playing his
outcast on his old ipod and it's like i
am for real boom he's like i am danny
right
[ __ ] don't you forget it oh my god
serial killer
or it's his uh or his friend the steel
serpent that other that other actor
who's
also not the greatest martial artist
yeah just it's all all of a sudden this
becomes an iron fist tie-in show if that
happens i'm gonna be like whoa this is
all a dream
yeah
they just lean heavily into iron fist
like midnight ends with a big title card
that says iron fist just boom
if you guys ever want to like watch a
shitty show together i actually made a
drinking game to the iron fist and it's
called iron double fisting
really wasted so if you guys want to if
you ever have
a double fisting
exactly no that's exactly what it is you
have to have a tall boy in each hand
while you play if your tall boy empties
whoo you've got to get a new one sorry
those are the rules personally i really
want this is random but i really want
ben barnes to play
casey jones in a ninja turtles movie
because he's just perfect for casey
jones in my pocket i want to play casey
jones
i want to play casey
yo i would love it just it would be
awful it would be awful
the hockey masterpiece
i don't deserve it i don't deserve that
she's like come on you turtle no
like wearing like with that hair and
everything like it would be perfect i
would watch the [ __ ] out of that show
i don't even i don't deserve to be
anything i would watch
a turtle yo
like just adjust casey jones with
raphael like that is a show that i would
watch the [ __ ] out of um but no
um
yeah but like what do you guys think
like who else could have been mark's
partner i
keeping it rogue over here
um
i
you know be crazy coming out of left
field no one would have anticipated
what if it's what if it's bucky
what if it was but yeah
during the time is still under siege his
mind is not just right and he was
ordered to go kill this man tie him up
and kill him up execution style like
bucky would and he's on that long list
of people that he needs to apologize to
his layla i don't think you guys
remember that on that notebook at the
very bottom it said layla right so
yeah we're pretty sure it's on my own
said layla right there definitely
actually we should revisit just to make
sure
honestly like that is a very plausible
really rogue theory because like i just
just because we know that hydra was
obsessed with this like occult stuff and
they were so obsessed with collecting
magical items so like if this
archaeologist guy what had like at least
the scarab maybe then like maybe hydra
would be like yeah we want we want that
we we want that we want to collect what
you have whatever you got so uh
kill that man kill that man arthur okay
okay kill that man
and episode 4 i like the author was like
um
oh he said like
you did you're following the dream that
your dad was already like
figured out and was trying to bring to
the people that god won't walk amongst
us and how that is like
that's it's like we don't need the world
to know that we need to take this man
out while we can so it's i feel like
he was like that's too much information
for anyone
uh that man was going to die eventually
so bucky was just like like running
around the planet killing people's dads
like he hit iron man's dead now he's got
to go get laila's dad why didn't he take
out my dad again
she would have made a pit stop at the
van lane house
no i need to do you just find a wrong
way
just a job
for legal reasons this is just a joke i
don't believe in killing people i've
never killed anyone i am not violent i
have a baby
don't let it be known that whitney still
does not like her dad
i don't like him he doesn't like me
either that's okay
no i really like this connection here
with bucky because like we know from
winter soldier that hydra had a very
similar goal to
harrow where like they wanted to
eliminate people that they saw were
threats to their overall agenda using
zola's formula so like what if like
this is a similar thing was happening
with um bucky and like you just needed
to eliminate these very
you know
like like this really uh too curious
archaeologist man who had all this magic
stuff and it was like hey i value target
we have to take them out because they
did have doctor strange on their hit
list like so they they they were all
about
magic people killing they name dropped
somebody from cairo too in that winter
soldier spot would like that you know
the anchor from cairo oh yeah they did
they did say
yeah yeah something's from cairo i
didn't think it was an um
i told y'all i said it maybe it was the
news anchor from kyra who killed
[Laughter]
she's probably saying the most real
theories that's great seriously jess is
the best because like she has like the
most robe but also very plausible
theories in this episode like it's like
it's too good
[Laughter]
um but wait which one you got wait wait
did you go with me i mean
i said myself and then i said danny rand
so i'm gonna stick with those two
answers baby me and danny down in egypt
just like us
honestly whatever you did whitney's dad
um
[Laughter]
i'm on i would be very surprised
but no like again jess your theory was
very plausible and like with with like
bucky being a you know this killer that
went around the world killing people for
hydra's weird magical aims out like that
we see what if it's like really super
mystic um i think it's really plausible
and i would love to see bucky pop up
because bucky needs to be in more mcu
stuff one day maybe he'll have his own
project who knows
yes i would love for bucky to pop up in
a flashback and be like hey let's go
kill some guys
why not dude becky's great i'm i'm team
bucky now too i think that that's that's
the right answer it's a good one i like
that answer so i'm gonna give jess ten
thousand rogue points for that one um
but i also do like this idea of this
this is a dude from the punisher coming
back because we we do know that there's
a huge military roots in that show and
like i would love for like to see more
or at least to get a confirmation that
frank castle from the netflix show is
coming to the mcu proper so for that
9 000 points for that and whitney even
though your answer was you and iron fist
baby
and i hate people
what are we up to um eight thousand
points for you because that is fun and
it's really fun to see iron fist like
even though like no hate to the actor
really oh yeah no hate to the actor it's
not his fault this was just a terrible
[ __ ] show it was like a lot of bad
decision-making it was no one person's
fault a lot of people had to be wrong to
make that television series so i would
love to see finn jones appear in the mcu
maybe in another role i think i think
he's a great actor but like do it i
think i think he's a great actor i would
rather prefer an asian iron fist
like personally
i don't know yes that was kind of part
of the problem
that was part of the issue yes but hey
be sure to check out our new
rockstarsmerch.com store and grab our
latest obsession shirt tomb of the moon
god it's the coolest shirt of all time
my favorite shirt look at all those
hieroglyphs mysteries to be unlocked in
this shirt an ancient curse on my sh my
chest this is inspired by the moon
knight series and this limited edition
shirt is selling fast and once it's sold
out it's gone forever we put it back
into the new rockstars vault so please
grab it while you can so go to new
rockstarsmerch.com to grab that today
how much it is time for our rogue
question game you ready for this ready
for a real question you ready because
netflix announced a dip in subscribers
for one of the first times in their
streaming history i wonder why i mean
it's only like they wanted to limited
password sharing and they increased the
prices and then like they just made
everything just really and they don't
have anything in their library so like
what is that's so weird that people
would leave
anyway this causes a big hit in their
stock price so guys imagine you were in
charge of programming at netflix and had
the power to make a show with any ip
that you wanted pitch me your rogus show
to save netflix and drive up subscribers
once again this is like a brand new show
or a show that netflix is already
running like you could like any ip like
it could be something that exists like
you can be your own show i know damn
well they ain't taking any more disney
show
they can't take it
and then they can't take anything from
fx so they got not settled with their
streams
um all right all right all right all
right i'm gonna pitch something that
someone's gonna steal
uh
something good
someone else go first i gotta think for
a minute i i didn't read these questions
i think that you know one well
one show that i i need to have happen is
like a metal gear solid show like if
they could i know moonlight started
working on it for real wait isn't there
a movie with oscar isaac yeah he's been
attached for like
years and years and years well before
moonlight i want to say moon knight i
want to say wow and um moonlight
before he was in the moonlight the
oscar-winning movie
they didn't win that awesome oscar isaac
movie
yeah the oscar isaac winning movie
moonlight yeah he was great in that um
but yeah
man they need to make a metal gear solid
movie but i think what's more realistic
of what they're gonna do is they they're
gonna need to create their own cinematic
universe at this point and what they
could do is use their existing eyepiece
to like to come together and you know
what stranger things is the way to do it
you know the upside down and all of a
sudden they get they instead of going to
the upside down 11 like uh 11 and the
kids go to like bridgerton
and then they go to like a squid game
and then they go to like house of cards
and [ __ ] all the netflix shows
that would be so
it would be great the kids in squid game
and then 11 just cheating using her my
powers to win that would be i'm sorry
but i would kill to see eleven in orange
is the new orleans or just a new black
breaking out
yeah she's like it's balled her tooth
yeah
[Laughter]
black mirror crossover and they'll
they'll break the walls of the netflix
dimension and go to every like spider
verse but it's a netflix verse
of movies that would be
really wild
um i love a good crossover ever since
like the ninja turtles crossed over with
the power rangers as a kid
everything anything was possible at that
point so uh yeah i would love to see
something like that because it's it's so
ridiculous that like a really fun thing
can happen from it i think it's fun
crossover was jimmy neutron and the
fairly odd parents
keep doing this and then when disney did
it i was like when disney had their
suite life of zach and cody raven simone
and hannah montana episodes
wait it was yeah it was like the sweet
life of that so hannah montana
that's so yeah
it was i don't know either way i went
put me up
yo yo when lilo and stitch crossed over
with like american dragon jake long oh
yeah
oh my god i ate that [ __ ] right now
right
so good yes
also people forget about jake law and
that was one of my favorite disney shows
that ever one of the most underrated or
forgotten shows like
the youths go to disneyplus.com
youtube about that and you guys forget
about dave the barbarian two of my
favorite shows that were back to back
and then first new groove would come on
at 6am did you know get the hell out get
out i don't even care about you anymore
i don't know i love you for a second and
i lost it i don't know about dave
you'll send a water soldier on your ass
empty
i think netflix a real talk this is real
talk not even rogue not even real talk
netflix was doing so well with their
really low budget romantic comedies i
think netflix was doing such a good job
becoming the next um
a hallmark station they were when they
got vanessa hutchins to play the
princess and not the princess and that
movie was done with like
props bought from the dollar tree it ate
it people were eating that up i think
they just need to continue making these
really bad romantic movies like even
because the teen ones and they don't
even have to be bad it's like to all the
boys i've loved was one of my favorite
things that ever came out it's like
people you can just adapt any young
adult romantic fiction book and just
make it just make it and it will cost
you 5 000 to make and then you'll make
the revenue so i think they should just
if it was me i would just keep doing
romantic movies and i know it's a niche
category but i love it and i would only
appease myself
so that's me
i do like a good romantic movie from
time to time i'm i'm a bit of a soft boy
that way but uh yeah i do agree
i'm a softboy i do like a good good
feeling a story about
maps god forbid it's dave the barbarian
then i'd turn it off because i'm not
freaking out
[Laughter]
the romantic plot of dave the barbarian
was not deep enough for me okay i needed
some more romance right
people do love the romance so i think
that would really you know help out
netflix why not but bring us home
whitney all right i'm gonna keep mine
short sweet to the point
i think that the only way that netflix
can keep me as a consistent subscriber
is if they start just putting out
straight up porn if netflix becomes a
porn service that i can jerk off to for
ten dollars a month no commercials
let's go isn't it called bridgeton
season one
oh you mean bridgerton season
episode
season two
yeah honestly
that type of adult content sells give me
some tips and if give me some tips if
you're gonna make it this expensive i'd
better be seeing some dick that's all i
have for you if if they were to produce
some content that was very good in the
adult arena and unique they would
probably save they should do it they
should link up with um i don't know um
the hub
um
when that black mirror episode came out
whitney was the one who's like
bandersnatch what is that let me watch
it
wait is this interactive bandits
netflix meeting whitney halfway and
being like what would just give you
titles that can somehow be confused
that sounds vaguely sexual yeah
you like iron fist here's double fist
it's like oh yeah
it's double
[Laughter]
all
i think punish her was the one who
killed uh the layla's dad that's what i
was talking about yeah yeah
killed his dad exactly he didn't pay for
his uh his netflix porn he didn't no he
didn't he missed a payment so he had to
go oh you know what i would really love
though is if netflix brought back the
business model where they used to send
you dvds in the mail i want to get some
porn dvds oh my god
why are you gonna play it on you they do
she's gonna look at the difference there
is a feature that somehow
you know what
you could just like play it like a
record player just pick it up just like
like a needle
i'll do it
you can do it netflix
all right we should probably wrap this
up um but no these are all very extra
rogue theories um especially wendy's
i think that means i win just saying
honestly
i want that
give whitney 20 000 rogue points for
that one because that is a really wild
rogue one um but honestly i gotta give
tom like 30 000 rogue points for that
one because like i would love to see a
huge netflix universe crossover because
i just i'm a sucker yeah that's like
cinematic you can do it the ncu
ncua but the ncu sounds way too similar
to the mcu like people would get that
they would totally do it though they
would totally do it like why not ncu why
not you know what i'm gonna give jess
forty thousand points for her for her
rook answer because i did the barbarians
yeah
[Laughter]
get back to bed
this makes just our winner for today's
wrong theory but of course you guys are
all winners because i love you guys so
much your brains are so creative and fun
and i love laughing with you guys the
most because that's what rogue theory is
all about laughing and having fun
um but anyways
that is it for this episode of rogue
theory thanks to our amazing guests
jessica clemens whitney van landingham
and of course tom michelson go support
them wherever they are on social media
they are the best and support our
channel by checking out all of our
awesome merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
and if you got some rogue theories of
your own you can share them on our
discord if you're over 18 check the link
in the description so you can check out
our discord server and just join the
conversation because we have a lot of
fun over there and you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some really weird [ __ ] and
fun theories you can follow new
rockstars wherever we are on social
media thank you guys so much for
watching we love you guys and appreciate
you so much and we'll see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
you